let's go now from Steve Ducey to Harris
Faulkner Harris Faulkner has become an
interesting character on Fox News Harris
Faulkner has become one of the greatest
Trump Brown nosers and Defenders on Fox
News and that's why it's particularly
interesting
that her review of Trump's speech
Tuesday night at Mar-A-Lago was not
exactly glowing now she does sort of Try
by the way this is not an image of
Harris Faulkner this is this is a this
is a guy Harris Faulkner is a black
woman and this is
um this is a man here uh you'll see her
in a moment
she can't effusively praise the speech
but she's kind of trying to defend it
and the point here is when even Harris
Faulkner is this lukewarm you know that
it's not very good post is a weird day
never thought I'd see it but here we are
picked upon uh with what you're saying
is right where Trump went from
Mar-A-Lago last night and that is you
know he didn't call it a whiff I'm gonna
call it one oh so she's calling it okay
interesting Alvin Bragg and I don't did
you see how someone's pointing that's
very very strange
someone's pointing almost like they want
the camera only on Harris Faulkner
during this speech that's very
interesting those those pans that pop up
follow the whiff I'm gonna call it one
when we see Alvin Bragg there before all
the reporters and they're pressing why
now and what new evidence and he's
dodging and weaving and pictures were
terrible they were terrible but he kept
talking so I mean it was just like it
was like nothingness coming out of his
mouth when you see that
Trump didn't stop there it didn't pick
up there where he went was but they'll
see they'll still be coming for me so
let me tell you what's coming I guess
he's saying the brag press conference
was a whiff it's so hard to know what
she's talking about Pike and I always
find it interesting and I did last night
for somebody to lay out a case before
you of how your enemies are coming to
get you to lay out the other cases get
ready they're gonna keep coming and here
are the holes in the next one
that Telegraph said he's not so worried
about this one not getting too far ahead
of it they still have to make motions by
August there's a date in August and of
course they want to push those to
December 4th but maybe it won't ever
happen
maybe we won't ever get to trial or
court or anywhere else with this case
but what we do know is he's playing
again the role of someone who wants to
solve the problems of the country okay
actually so this is this is actually
much more delusional than I thought
talked about that he he mentioned the
things that Americans are going through
and at the same time don't think that
they're not going to come get me again
and again and again as they always do as
they did today because I'm trying to
save the country it was interesting it
was short he read the Proctor he left
from a political messaging standpoint
though all right well I guess I mean I
don't know it's the
first of all wasn't reading from a
teleprompter bad he showed up he read
the prompter and he left Trump spent
years saying that Obama reading from a
teleprompter was some form of cheating
and dishonesty and Fox News spent years
agreeing that Obama reading from a
teleprompter is dishonesty then Trump
used a teleprompter his entire four
years and then used one on Tuesday night
and now listen he showed up he did what
he had to do he read off of his prompter
and he left the the real Point here
though is the idea that Trump described
to Americans the things that Americans
are going through Trump talked about the
National Archives classified documents
hush money payoffs a perfect phone call
Ukraine these are the issues that
Americans are going through that's an
extraordinarily who hasn't been indicted
for 34 felonies let's all come together
as Americans so listen I think Harris
Faulkner knows it wasn't exactly a
titillating performance that people were
expecting Trump with fire he's sort of
low energy while very sweaty and visibly
confused read his speech off the
prompter it was the standard set of
grievances we've been hearing at every
rally and nobody was particularly
impressed with it outside of the Fox
News bubble one guy who was clearly
desperate that night
seemingly knowing how poorly it went was
Trump himself because he ended up doing
something he doesn't often do Trump
turned to God